we're here at the LG booth at CES 2016
behind me is an 8k TV now AK TVs have
been in prototype form actually the last
three or four shows from various
companies LG says this one is actually
going to come to market this year now 8k
is 16 times the resolution of HD four
times the resolution of 4k so what we're
talking about is your frame on an HD
video is about 2 megapixels frame on a
4k video is about 8 megapixels each
frame on this TV is 32 megapixels
there's a reason why they're showing a
bunch of still images because there's
not a lot of 8k content out there we've
got 4k was hard to find AK is nearly
impossible to find but in terms of
display technology this is probably
about 10 years down the line so you
might not be able to see a big
difference between 8k and 4k on this
video but if you're really really close
to this set especially if it's a big
screen you're going to see a major
difference this basically looks like
printed out photographs that are moving
around it doesn't look digital at all
you can get right close to the screen
there's absolutely no evidence of
pixilation at all it almost has a 3d
effect because your eyes just are not
used to seeing something this sharp
that's digitally produced